when two of abdullahi bullet hero's
children died of hunger and thirst he
says he was left with no choice
he abandoned the only life he's ever
known as a nomadic herder
he says he was caught between the armed
group al-shabab and worsening drought
most of his goats and cows perished he
told us he left the last animals to die
and walked with his surviving daughter
fardosa for three weeks to reach here
a camp for displaced people in the port
city of kismayo in somalia
my wife lost her mind with grief that
was after we were unable to get food for
our children the last i heard she tried
to walk to mogadishu i don't have the
strength to look for her i don't have
shelter i don't have anything to eat i
have nothing
abdullahi and fardosa have joined
thousands of people already in this camp
many of them lost their animals in
previous droughts and haven't been able
to restock their herds
more than half of somalis depend on
herding
livestock turned dry scrub into milk and
meat that people have survived on for
thousands of years
but the droughts are becoming more
frequent and worse
so the camps in cities like kismayo grow
bigger many of the people here may never
go back
it's getting harder and harder for
people to survive in the countryside but
there's another food source here the
fish
in the sea and there are many decades of
conflict and piracy of prevented
industrial fishing but unlike many other
parts of the world the seas here haven't
been overfished
abdullahi muhamed says he would never
have dreamt of eating fish when he was a
herder
then his sheep and goats were wiped out
in a drought five years ago he says he
then struggled to survive in a camp in
kismayo until the un's food and
agriculture organization bought him a
boat and trained him to fish
there's a big difference
as a livestock keeper life is always
about struggling with drought and trying
to recover from it to fish in the ocean
you have to learn many things the ocean
itself is like a university you need to
study how it works
abdullahi spent years learning and says
he can now get a good catch five days a
week
says the money he earns is enough to pay
school fees for his children the un says
many more people could be helped in the
same way
the idp crisis is also becoming an
urbanization crisis and
it requires a more durable solution by
supporting the fisheries sector which
has a huge potential where they can
diversify
and improve their food security
livelihood and nutrition
it's not clear how the millions of
somalis in the countryside will survive
in a warmer world or what they'll eat
maybe somalia's three thousand kilometer
coastline and its fish can help
malcolm webb al jazeera kismayo somalia